mit ihrem einsatz bewegen will kulturen
swisslos stimme vergeben
wir sind heute ein innersten der macht
im bundesratszimmer hier trifft die
regierung ihre entscheide ja und selten
waren diese entscheide so weitreichend
für uns alle
wie im vergangenen jahr hier treffe ich
gleich alt bundesrat moritz leuenberger
und befrage ihn zur aura der macht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
willkommen auf den kulturplatz ja
vielleicht fragen sie sich was denn die
kultursendung in der zentrale der
schweizer regierungsmacht verloren hat
eine berechtigte frage denn beweist dass
es sich hier um ein absolut kultur
relevantes gehandelt denn er bringen wir
später in der sendung
zuerst aber schauen wir auf eine nuklear
jahrhundertkatastrophe
nach fukushima vor zehn jahren lebte an
der ostküste japans die erde
die folgen kennen wir alle der schweizer
kriegsfotograf domenica war nur einen
tag nach dem unglück vor ort und ist
immer wieder dorthin zurückgekehrt wäre
ganze dörfer weggeschwemmt verwüstung
zerstörung aufs bild gebannt von
dominique nach der fotoreporter war
nicht nur einer der ersten die 2011 die
katastrophe in fukushima festhielten
er dokumentierte das ausmaß und die
folgen auch so umfangreich wie kein
zweiter über jahre
[Musik]
bilder die sich ins gedächtnis brennen
aus denen nun ein buch entstehen soll
bilder wie bei dominic nahr anti gefühle
wecken
ich habe sehr viele bilder gemacht in
der rest also ich schätze über 150
bilder und von denen 150 bilder bin ich
jetzt nur ali bildet organe weil im
moment denkst du das bild aber wenn
jetzt zurück legt sie ja später dennis
bild petra tabelle wo für mich
funktioniert und so gar nicht halt durch
alle bilder alle geschehe das ist als
virgin fahrer vergangenheit sogar als
motopädin hunger
der 37-jährige ausdrucks anfang 2011 war
er dort zu besuch bei seiner schweizer
mutter
diese schwere zeit für mich meine
vaterstadt stoiber ich bin neu in kairo
xiii und fotografiert revolution
und wenn ich mir vater gestorben darum
wäre eine renaissance trotz großem fest
zögerte fotojournalist keine sekunde den
nächstbesten flieger nach japan zu
erwischen kann ich somit breit auf japan
und darum mich alles sehr neu und die
geschichte sind nach wenn sie nicht
verloren
ich weiß nicht ein anderer grund sie
aber ich war irgendwie könne direkt mit
verstehe was passiert ist dass es wegen
des tsunami zu einer nuklearkatastrophe
kam
davon gehörte den gästen nach der wand
dieser job würde alles bisher erlebte
betreffen also schon sehr viele orte in
der welt wo es ruhig anspacher also wo
es sehr schwer ich bin das mache ob es
jetzt in somalia oder in irak sieht dann
kongo hätte also gleich wo aber auf
einmal ist ganz in neue szenario basiert
dass er sich wirklich sehr intensive und
so großes frau gezeigt was heißt das
überhaupt werde man ja wie schlimm ist
wenn man wenn es nix
trotz angst und unsicherheit arbeitet
nachts auftrag des timer gesehen erst
einmal ausserhalb der evakuierten roten
zone dann besorgt der schutzanzug und
geigen zähler und wagt sich so zusammen
mit einem kollegen in das arc
verstrahlte gebiet
gerade im april wo es erst morgen bin
hat man einfach seine ins ohne fahrer
und den farben mit einem vollzug und und
denkt bei meinem auto blieb habe ich
auch fest ich musste zu stehen
die tat die bilder sind nicht rasch und
im auto machen den steg schuss und ich
habe im grunde im kopf erzählt wie lange
bin ehrt aus dem auto durch die
unsichtbare gefahr macht dominique nach
sichtbar
die hals über kopf verlassen häuser
verbindet
und im kurs wieder ins auto und dann
hätte mini radioaktivität wieder checkt
und das ding macht so viel größer und ja
ich will ganz klar ich weiß was das
heißt
wie viel strahlung abbekommen
er befürchte zu eröffnen eine diagnose
gibt etwa trotz allem kette immer wieder
nach japan zurück
für ein paar tagen monaten
2014 bekommt der zutritt zu einem
geborstenen reaktor
sein interesse gilt aber nicht der
technik in den menschen den schicksale
der opfer
[Musik]
er besucht kranke kinder
familien die ihre hoffnung auf eine
intakte zukunft begraben haben
in notunterkünften festsitzt
thematisiert die hohe selbstmordrate in
fukushima city glaubt und 20 14 und mit
der nachbar von mir hat sich um braucht
dich betriebs gedenkt sie in der 36
und er ist die kontamination der causa
hypo wo die radioaktivität weg rund vor
deiner verschiedene orte und sollen dank
merkt dass ich so in der irgendwie in
tränen die gesellschaft dass das öfters
passiert auch sie versuchte sich
umzubringen
dominic nahr besuchte rooney mara
camille 2016 in der temporären
unterkunft in der sie ihren kindern seit
jahren fest sie zeigt ihm die
psychopharmaka
ohne dieses denn nicht alle haben vom
energiegiganten genug
kompensationszahlungen für einen
neuanfang bekommen
neid missgunst vertrauensverlust die
gesellschaft ist gespalten vergiftet
nicht nur wegen der radioaktivität dass
ich so so krass wie viele vereine leben
im web ihrem noch bei diesen komplett
verstreut wurde und sind ganz allein und
für sie das gefühl ich einfach dass der
rechner japan wieder gange ist und ihre
serbische staat lieber gemeinsam gehen
sie zurück in ihre alte nach wie vor
versteht
in der sperrzone sieht es vielerorts
noch fast so aus wie einen tag nach dem
tsunami sie ist sogar zur schule wo sie
kennt und und der heimat der rücklauf
und die dass ich extrem emotional physik
sie das tut sie und xavi wir alles weg
schien als wäre es lieber hätte auf
einen punkt abrufen und schulbücher sind
der dinge und tesche sind nur diene aber
das gras ich jetzt einfach so groß dass
man einfach schon im torlauf everest
zieht die steht still gestanden
er hat das gefühl dass man nicht kann
auf höhere zucker die fifa muss immer
wieder auch die psychologe visier gordon
ihre geschichte erzählen
[Musik]
dominique meyer kämpft gegen das
vergessen
will daran erinnern dass alles was
geschehen ist unsere gegenwart und
unsere zukunft bringt alle fotografiert
von willi eine reales vergesse haase
minute mann des kinderzimmers sie hätten
ihm ausbildet wiedersehen auf einmal
oxytocin also und daher millimeter
kamera die hexe fotograf wäre das nicht
vergisst sich was sowas passiert und
eben jan ich das mit mir selber gemacht
und so ist das der neu entwickelte sie
zu dem job wenn das bild nicht existiert
dann wäre es als wäre es nicht passiert
was passiert ist in fukushima hat nach
bis 2018 dokumentiert nutzt er die
korona bedingt reise freie zeit ein werk
der erinnerung zu schaffen
mit einer exklusiven auswahl aus 150
tausend bildern und einer zentralen
frage wie kann ein buchmacher dass nicht
nur über fukushima aber auf erzählt wie
man sich fühlt wenn nötig was macht das
mit menschen
also ich das buch in dem sie nicht
wichtig so oft das ist etwas was gefühl
hat vorrang - bilder sind ein paar
eine erinnerung für einen besseren
umgang mit mensch und natur in der
zukunft die atomare katastrophe von
fukushima hat ja auch große auswirkungen
auf die schweizer politik 2011
debattierte der bundesrat über einen
möglichen ausstieg aus der atomenergie
und dieses thema beschäftigt uns bis
heute aber nun ist es an der zeit ihnen
reinen wein einzuschenken dieses
bundesratszimmer ist nicht im bundeshaus
in bern zu finden sondern im
landesmuseum in zürich
[Musik]
es ist ein ziemlich genauer und doch
ganz eigenwillige nachbau im maßstab 1
zu 6 gefertigt vom zürcher künstler
kollektiv grün die halle
das material für diesen nachbau stammt
allesamt aus dem brockenhaus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das chalet federer ist mit vielen
typisch schweizerischen details gespickt
[Musik]
ja und da begrüße ich es der alt
bundesrat moritz leuenberger von 119
bisherige bundesrat in der bundesrat die
schweizer sauber wieder zurück im
zentrum von der macht also schon gemerkt
dass uns gott was ist aus ihren original
aber das ist ganz herzlich also ich
könnte mir jetzt vorstelle mit der bank
oder bundes spielen
der normalverbraucher im
bundesratszimmer sitze für einmal aber
wie das wirklich sich aufhält weil die
atmosphäre herrscht das hat sie erlebt
nach wellen regler fehlt dann so eine 70
statt wie muss man sich das vorstellen
es ist also nicht so dass da dass man
irgendwie streik treten sondern das ist
strange erzählt ist der konzern worden
so weiter also das ist alles so geregelt
was was aber nicht was sind sie per sie
da gibt es dann allerdings auf 1000
grafikkarten gruben aber trenkmann
kapitän sein
und da geht es jetzt wieder offen für
komische nein das hat sie in die
berechtigung will die die größten
differenzen wo man mit ein und hat sie
in lodz funktion bedingt also es ist
doch klar
in infrastruktur oder und will sparen
oder und damit man nicht gegeneinander
unanständig wird oder ob ihr seid ja das
muss jetzt mehr zu machen so auf der
orden wie ist haben wir natürlich mit
dem konsens finden ist der sitz ist
regel sehr agnes wenn es sind denn die
größten lieferanten die größte konflikt
wo sie streiten die den ruhm
also ich will wissen wo wir in den seen
und crew mitglieder vom bundesrat ich
habe zugehört dann verkaufen wenn die es
wissen
ground konkurs geht also den 20
das ist der verwaltungsrat der in syrien
schuld ist aber im moment wo das
unmittelbar bevorstehenden ist dass die
zehn kugeln und ixload entlastend
arbeitslos werden kalium dankt und sind
alle autos entstehen mitunter mehr
gekommen andere zitate der bundesrat
muss ordentlich viel macht halten sie
das für richtig jetzt sieht ein corona
jahr ist einiges anders und muss einfach
aufpassen dass man macht nicht immer
also bis absolut 1x geld machte jemand
mit einer großer verantwortung verbunden
sei 50 grad macht und verfügungsgewalt
war doch wahnsinnig wichtig da lastete
waren sie in die verantwortung auf die
offen gegen bundesrat und ein beheiztes
zelt keine jäger oder in englischen dank
dazu jetzt wird da macht es gibt also
ganz im gegenteil weiß was das bedeutet
wenn man etwas nach außen zeigen wir
alle könnten nicht alle oder branche und
wolle die viele entscheider bundesrat
muss fälle jetzt dem chor ohne ja so
viel druck ist da auf dein zimmer auf
denen natürlich und jeder brief 1000
beamten hat viel erfolg fasst ich meine
könnten aber plötzlich ganz ein anderer
aspekt und das hat ihre immer wieder
überlegt dass man gesagt ja bereits
gesagt das muss ich sagen doch das
überzeugt mich und so hätte man eben
einige landet und so sind in einem
konsens bestand haben wird am schluss
muss es ja ein konsens über vor allem 73
geht also das heißt es wird auch immer
wieder mal der ein oder andere aktuelle
situation wo unser gott und konnte
bisher
der konsens natürlich auch noch den
abstieg
doch ständige will man wenn möglich
vermieden
er sei dann abstimmen aber wenn es ganz
hart auf hart kommt dann wird eben
abstimmung nach hause 4 zu 3
und dann ist wichtig dass dir drüber
unterlagen sind trotzdem konsensual mit
den mehrheitsentscheid klappt ist es
gute argumente und sie schon umgekehrt
bin ich in der mehrheit und und so
durchkommen noch mit gutem gewissen
trotzdem für bis ich da wo man
vielleicht klage stimmen aber ist dann
in dem moment wo wir jetzt sind die
dammkrone ja wo soviel schnell
entscheiden mit gefällt wäre ist dann
das gremium überhaupt noch die richtige
instanz zum team entscheide fällen
ich meine der alternative das war der
starke mann der sofort irgendwie
entscheidet und da ist das gerade das
beispiel dass sie bald aus verschiedenen
kunden ihre regionen verschieden jackpot
am an verschiedenen die beamten im
hintergrund miteinander diskutieren und
seine lösung findet das ist demokratie
und ich würde sagen dass ich viel viel
effizienter im schluss als wenn einer
ganz schlechten zeiten des
bundestrainers ist
in der aktuellen ausstellung das ist
natürlich die bundesrätinnen und
bundesräte sind auf dem 4
[Musik]
wir machen einen sprung weg von der
politischen elite hin zum geldadel und
schauen nach sankt moritz auch in diesem
winter wurde dort die eine und andere
berühmtheit gesichtet und auch neben der
piste wollte man diesen solventen gab es
natürlich etwas bieten dafür wurde kunst
hoch geschafft ins engadin und zwar von
niemand geringerem als von britischen
opfer terrible dem in höchst
[Musik]
stehen
neueste geschichte 2010 werden die nicht
teddy bear toss
der kunststoff
die geschichte war
erst nachdem
hier oben kippen
das ist kein zufall
wir höchstens kunst kaufen will
s
dann wie auf eine gute geschichte
[Musik]
die aus dem mit organisiert hat damit
kann man für den hass ist klar die kunst
geht dorthin wo die klientel ist
publicity wirksam postete er dazu auf
gestern den spektakulären ausbruch
sie kann solange der weichen
ein kamin
das sieht auch der gemeindepräsident des
touristenortes christian jott jenny
nicht anders der staat muss sich nicht
vorm auch dass er glaubt die wüste sehr
sehr genau was sie machen ihr sterben
mit dass der termin hörst klosters oder
in zurzach oder sogar gerne nickel sei
die umstellung gemacht hätte also nicht
genannte dürfen aber natürlich hat er
ist sich bewusst dass sich die stadt
sankt moritz polarisiert der gewisses
klientel will ich das in ein grundstück
passiert ist meistert das kunststück die
nähe zu den superreichen zufrieden und
kraft seien wichtig
in der neunzigerjahre kopiert sogar noch
mit adaptive halten erhöht doch schon
sein mit diamanten bestückter toten hat
erinnerte mehr an eine gans am kunst-
und als er dann 2006 rasen wieder
finanzkrise jetzt ein wechsel auf den
weg brachte
mit dem tonnenschweren seine verkaufs
nach der ausstellung mit dem titel
geistige entwässerung
der schnellste
dass sich ein
sprechen sieht man ein bisschen von
allem was first bildsprache ausmacht
und sie uns
des todes sind
12 und dem bilder etwas entgegensetzen
vergänglich ist dann auf st
fitschen
verkaufte er
die aufgerichtete sich nach dem
[Musik]
fast schon schwer
die politische macht sie wird hier in
der aktuellen ausstellung im
landesmuseum zürich dargestellt wie sich
macht und gewalt zueinander verhalten
das war eines der zentralen themen der
deutschen philosophin hannah arendt die
große denke hin lebte in den usa war
aber gerne im tessin in den ferien so
auch im sommer 1975 kurz vor ihrem tod
über diese letzten tage im leben der
hannah arendt hat jetzt die
literaturwissenschaftlerin hildegard
keller einen roman geschrieben
sie erscheinen brauchen wir regeln das
leben einer der bedeutendsten förderung
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
der kritischen denken die story kann
abend überraschend ab
[Musik]
wie
selbst war die schweizer
die tat keinerlei professoren in den usa
deshalb das leben zwischen zwei kulturen
sie hatten
deren betreten verspielten seite
beleuchten die figur bruch den roman als
läppisch
ich hatte ja nicht einfach ihnen kräftig
sperre von biografischen fakten das
langweilig die kinder bekannt ich habe
ein ganzes neues land aufbrechen oder
unbekannte hannah arendt zu der
unbekannten bekannten wie die
philosophen denkt und wahrnimmt was sie
träumt und fühlt und wie sie die kleinen
fragen des lebens genießt das beschreibt
keller stets unterwegs meist allein und
taxis
[Musik]
die kleinen zu kontinent
im letzten lebensjahr die philosophin
beginnt der roman ohne zu blinken bog
der wagen nach links ab gleich linker
hand kommt der kirchturm von denia so
lange schon habe ich kein gedicht mehr
geschrieben warum eigentlich
da rumpelte es noch einmal und der wagen
kam mit einem kleinen ruck zum stehen
eco professor ist ja wohl über die casa
bavaria quester hanna ins letzte reise
nach kenia
einen kleinen dorf
ist eine reise zu sich selbst und zieht
sich als rahmenhandlung wird das gift
martin wird bietet
bekannt und bewährt so einen einblick in
sein
sie hätte ganz so ausgeprägt gefühl für
die privatsphäre k und trotzdem an die
welle so nah wie möglich zu machen ihre
innere gedanken chöre ihren ihren
inneren monolog was fließt darin wege
permanent durch figuren der andere
erzählen strand für die lese den
chronologisch durch die wichtigen
immunzellen an allen spielen
1941 jeder auswanderung nach
mit ihrer mutter und ihren ehemann
eigentlich bücher
anfänger als publizistin jede zeit als
professor in der politischen theorie
1960 der jahrhundertprozess in israel
wegen der pss kriegsverbrecher adolf
eichmann berichtet von den new york
times und kompliziert an den wochenenden
zu nehmen die schlussrunden
statt in
die wahlergebnisse liest du eine facette
gegen sie aus die leute nehmen mir eine
sache und das kann ich gewissermaßen für
stimmen von außen nämlich dass ich da
noch lachen kann und ich war wirklich
der meinung dass der eichmann ein
hanswurst ist und ich sage ihnen ich
habe dieses polizeiverhör 3600 seiten
gelesen und sehr genau gelesen und ich
weiß nicht wie oft ich gelacht dabei ein
land das war die dummheit die so empören
worden das habe ich eigentlich gemeint
mit der banalität fasziniert der hannah
arendt nicht ganz sicher die unerhört
die eigenständigkeit vor der frau wurden
denkerin um ihre erste der arbeitnehmer
die ganze radikalität wirklich
aufgegangen ist
mit original auszügen aus dem tagebuch
versucht die autorin im roman spüren zu
lassen wie die bekannten gewinnt die
langwierige und schwierige vorhaben
um dieser hass kampagne nach der
eichmann publikation verarbeitet
dass es gefährlich sein kann die
wahrheit zu sagen
um das zu wissen brauchen wir weder
hitler noch stalin welche die lüge
selbst zum rang der wahrheit erhoben
dass das thema so gewesen und der grund
ist politisch es ist immer einer gegen
alle nicht weil einer so klug ist und
alle so dumm sondern der denk- und
suchprozess der schließlich zur wahrheit
führt immer nur von einem geleistet
werden kann
dieser denkt und suchprozess schlug sich
bei einer
die knie
[Musik]
dann werde ich laufen wie ich einst es
lief doch gras und walten fällt dann
wird zu stehen wie du einmal stand der
innigste groß von der welt karins
eigenständige und eigenwillige suche
nach der wahrheit versucht keller in
ihrem buch auf den grund zu gehen kann
arendt mit ihrer art mit dem lebens
konfrontieren macht mut zum eigenen weg
ich bin sauer bis wichtigsten titel
davon herdenimmunität und influenza und
der followers und was gibt's da noch
alles ja auch schwarmintelligenz
überzeugt sie will nicht nur milch
lächele zu all deine phänomen ein buch
über eine alte bekannte das als
inspiration dienen soll für heute
[Musik]
das war unser ausflug zu einem raum von
großer bedeutung auch sie können sich
dort hinein setzen und die aura der
macht auskosten
die aktuelle ausstellung im landesmuseum
zürich zu den bundesrätinnen und
bundesräten ist bis november dieses
jahres zu sehen
ja und nächste woche dann nehmen wir sie
mit auf einem bio-bauernhof und zeigen
ihnen wie trotz krise die zuversicht
sprießen kann gleich jetzt folgt die
serie vor sie würden kommen sie gut
durch die woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegende kultur
wissen